19 countries one currency and now europe
is marking 20 years of the euro it's
been a roller coaster a couple of
decades for the single currency for some
the euro has been a stabilizing factor
for the continent others say it's just
driven up prices as we wait to see what
the future holds for the euro let's
first take a look at the past
a symbol of hope and prosperity for all
of europe
the six-story high eurosculpture in
front of the european central bank in
frankfurt
it was germany's way of celebrating the
introduction of the euro as legal tender
since then europeans don't have to
exchange notes and coins when traveling
within the eurozone
companies also profited as trade within
the currency union sharply increased on
the eve of 2022 more than 340 million
people in 19 eu countries use the common
currency every day
at its introduction one euro cost one us
dollar and seven cents since then it has
gone up and up in 2008 it reached its
all-time high of almost 1 us dollar and
60 cents just before the start of the
global financial crisis
there was also the first real test for
the euro a single currency for economies
as different as greece and germany a
recipe for disaster
the eu had to agree on a billion euro
rescue packages to save the weaker
countries of southern europe from
financial collapse
the crisis put the euro under
unprecedented pressure speculators tried
to cash in on the failure of the common
currency
in 2012 the president of the ecb spoke
words that would go down in history
the ecb
is ready to do whatever it takes
to preserve the euro
and believe me it will be enough
the ecb was pushing the envelope and it
worked
the euro survived the financial crisis
today
a tough new test
the corona pandemic lockdowns have
placed a heavy burden on the national
budgets of the euro countries in 2020
they took on joint debt for the first
time ever
critics of the euro say this move makes
financially weaker countries a burden on
those with stronger economies many
others however still see the euro as the
best opportunity for the european union
countries to grow even closer
[Music]
well to discuss further 20 years of the
euro let's speak to maria demensis who's
deputy director of the brussels economic
think tank brugal thanks a lot for
joining us on dw business it's great to
have you on so two decades in can we say
whether the euro has been a success or
not
yes of course i think the euro has been
uh has been a a big success actually and
and a way of thinking about this is
imagine how countries small countries
but also big countries would have
weathered
the two big crisis that we've seen in
the past 20 years had they been alone
i think that's a very important thing to
try and contemplate as of a thought
experiment and then you realize that the
scale and the stability that the euro
has brought to the continent different
degrees for different countries has
actually managed to keep uh europe
together and actually weather the crisis
with much less cost than it would have
been otherwise so yes it has been an
outright success as far as i'm concerned
but as you just mentioned the impact of
it has varied between countries have
there been winners and losers from the
last 20 years
i think it's important to appreciate
that not all countries joined uh the
euro indeed the eu for the same reasons
uh to the extent that one can have a
distinction between the north and the
south and i'm very reluctant to make
these types of comparisons because
they're never really accurate but let's
say for the sake of conversation we we
divide the continent in these two blocks
the northern countries are more open
countries so they are the ones who are
looking
for a greater markets so they're real
the prime motivation for the northern
part of europe to join the eu is to
expand their markets both domestically
domestically meaning in europe but
through scale also internationally
globally
and and that of course the euro provided
amply to countries of the north
countries in the south on the other hand
wanted stability they wanted a stable
currency that is going to ensure that
the consumer has got predictability in
terms of purchasing power in their
pockets and they got up with the euro so
yeah to that extent if you sort of think
about the motivation why every country
joined the eu
then all of them had something to uh to
win from
the adjustment to the uh to the euro
hasn't been easy for all countries that
i think is is important countries in the
south found it a lot more difficult to
adapt simply because their economies are
a lot more inflexible
but i think even countries in the south
have found the stability of the euro to
be an option right success it survived
two decades and it's got through various
crises but there is another one on the
way as the eurozone recovers from the
pandemic how well set is the euro to get
through that
i think you'll see that uh european
architecture which is absolutely
essential for a good architecture i mean
for sustaining shocks or sustaining
crisis has been going has been moving in
the right direction compare the reaction
how europe dealt with the financial
crisis uh and at what speed and to the
reaction of the eu in the current crisis
the pandemic crisis in 2020 and at what
speed you'll see that both the unity of
europe as well as the speed of reaction
have greatly improved there is a thing a
sincere realization appreciation of the
fact that a united europe can really
weather these storms much faster there
are very important discussions in 2022
when it comes to architectural issues
i'm thinking mostly of the fiscal pact
that can really help increase the
resilience of the continent and i think
there is enough understanding that
important steps forward need to happen
okay maria de meza's from brugel thank
you very much for joining us on dw
business